this guy was burying two people in his
basement when i'm knocking on the door
oh my god i'm comedian ryan sickler and
this is my stepson derek crawford while
we were on quarantine class might have
been out but school was still in session
all right let's go
very serious business you have lives
especially this one
in your literal hands and feet
it was like an old country road and it
had an awesome hill to jump jumping them
yeah dude we jumped the [ __ ] out of them
oh no hold on look at it
look at the aloha whoa
just heavy on the brakes i mean jesus
christ stay in your lane you're hurting
jerky with turns this is learner permit
shout out to ups baltimore hub primary
one joe avenue i'm going to remember
that that's one go ahead try and say it
yeah going on right now say it right now
give it a shot i just no i'm just saying
like i'm going to remember it by the end
of all this of all this i think i will
when i worked there i i couldn't get i
couldn't get a job i could not get a job
i was over 21 on this recession of
applying in my grand i live with my
grandmother at the time so when my dad
died with the state we had to move in
with my mom but she just left us there
she went to a boyfriend so we were by
ourselves for we raised ourselves for
like two and a half years
then moved in with my grandmother to go
to school so
i decided i looked into selling my sperm
because i thought well
i could do that 10 times a day
but what i didn't know
about sperm donation was that you can
only do it two times in a certain mile
radius and i never even considered it
because it may be improbable but it's
not impossible that if you had
donated sperm to five women those five
kids if they stayed in that area have a
chance of meeting
connecting unbeknownst to them being
incestual and not even know they're
related because they're in a certain
mile rate and i was like what so that
job was out plus my grandmother was like
you can't do that they're still your
children
so
then i went for ups like right after she
had died i went downtown baltimore city
to the unemployment office and i got
this job as a driver's helper during the
holiday season where
i literally was picked up on my front
porch and um one day we're out doing
this run the rule was
at least for there
out of sight outer weather
excuse me yeah
out of sight out of weather so
i go
up to this house and i
i knock on the front door and i hear
people in there
go down to lincoln and make a left yes
ma'am
shut up patty my home and then
i i saw i go all right i'm gonna walk
around
hey jim
[Music]
so i knock on the back door i go around
the back where i'm gonna leave it on
their deck or under their deck or
whatever
and uh i hear him i hear him in there i
knock on the door again
nothing i come back around the front
driver's like what's going on i'm like i
don't know i could definitely hear him
in there there's people in there they're
just not answering the door so i knock
on the front again nothing i'm like all
right let me go around back
leave it out back i go around back i
bang on the door one more time just for
the hell of it i slide the package we
get in the truck this is probably noon
i want to say sometime earlier in the
day yeah we get back
and the supervisor was like man
how about that crazy guy on your route
today we're like who are you talking we
encounter 50 crazy people a day on our
route who are you talking about and um
he's like the guy that killed those
people we're like huh
dude this is in the baltimore sun i have
links to it lincoln yeah this guy was
burying two people in his basement or
had already buried him but he had two
dead people in there when i'm knocking
on the door okay
this dude this idiot
owed a couple drug dealers i mean
not much money and he was the type of
white trash
that had cars on his yard that he could
have sold each car for 500 and made up
that stupid debt it was nothing
but he went out to where i grew up uh in
carroll county went out to patapsco
state park to meet these two guys he
owed money to
and he killed both of them
took him back to his place and decided
he was going to bury him in the basement
and he started digging up the basement
to bury him but he hit water pipes now
the pipes are busted and he can't the
bodies are just in there he can't bury
him yeah and what he didn't know is that
one of the dudes in the that he killed
just had a baby i think with his
girlfriend
and she called the police and said hey
my boyfriend left with the baby he's
been gone for hours this is the car they
were in this is where they were going
this is who they went to to find
and they get there the baby thank god's
fine
and they go right to that dude's house
and we didn't have to be witnesses or
anything because they got there and the
bodies were in there they said it was a
mess it was a scene in that thing and
i'm knocking on the door while he's got
that body yeah dude yeah
i walked who that guy yeah or he didn't
hear me he said he just kept working
speaking of ups right there
shout out to ups baltimore hall primary
one joe avenue
[Music]
[Music]
you